la situación de los hospitales en
portugal es bastante preocupante sobre
todo la situación en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos a la fecha se han
registrado 843 personas internadas en
estas unidades y ya los hospitales no se
dan abasto de incluso esto llevado al
ministerio de salud a transferir
pacientes de unos hospitales a otros
para intentar de aliviar esta presión en
los centros de salud incluso
transferirlos desde portugal continental
hasta la isla de madeira la prensa ha
calificado el mes de enero como el más
letal en portugal pues ya suma más de
cinco mil los fallecidos sólo en lo que
va de año
portugal al registrado un total de
fallecidos por kobe 19 de más de 12.000
y más de 5000 se registraron sólo en el
mes de enero e incluso la ministra de
salud de esta semana asomaba la
posibilidad de transferir pacientes
fuera de portugal para que sean ayudados
por otros países este domingo entran
nuevas medidas para intentar aliviar la
situación en portugal entre ellos sera
prohibición de salida del país a todos
los portugueses y restricciones en la
frontera